I am so honored to be here and I've
watched these ETL sessions for years so
it's it's a great excitement for me to
be here today as Matt pointed out I'm
the founder and CEO of zoom a company I
founded four years back actually a quick
walk from here right there in GSB and
the idea of the zoom was refined right
here in engineering school as part of a
two for five lean launchpad so excited
to be back at engineering school and
sharing my journey with you zoom is an
idea we are solving a universal parent
parenting challenge how to take your kid
safely and reliably from one place to
another how to transport them and take
care of them at the same time we have
built a platform for schools and parents
where we provide any size of the asset
to them and a certified and vetted
drivers when they need it and where they
need it to just to give you an idea of
how big this problem is there are 63
million families in us who face this
problem every single day and 10 million
women in us have already left job to
take care of their children schools and
Willie spend 35 billion dollars on very
suboptimal school transportation system
where kids end up spending 60 to 90
minutes on each on on a bus trip each
time so it's a it's a very large problem
in past 24 months we have grown 10 times
in terms of revenue we have grown our
teams by 12 times and we have read we
have been fortunate enough to raise over
71 million dollars from some of the very
prestigious pcs in the Silicon Valley in
this time we have also driven children 5
million miles and we have saved
California schools over 15 million
dollar and parents hundred plus years of
their time that they would otherwise
spend on the road driving their children
around
so zoom today is a late-stage startup
with a pretty exciting growth trajectory
and that's all is actually
pretty amazing to me as a kid I aspire
to be an astronaut at that time growing
up in India in a country of 1 billion
people there was only one astronaut but
that didn't stop me from dreaming my
parents actually had created me to dream
often and dream big while I did not
become an astronaut what had left my
interest in science and technology
actually led me to be the first person
in my family to get accepted in a
computer engineering program it was a
top school in India there were 300
students but only 6 women at that time
in the Indian society engineering was
not supposed to be a very fit course for
women while I was taking the course I
kept hearing about Silicon Valley this
magical place called Silicon Valley
which was a fantastic place for
technology enthusiasts and people were
launching their moonshots here all the
time after I finished my degree I moved
to Silicon Valley here and I studied at
Stanford work there's several well-known
companies in the Silicon Valley and
finally eventually that led me to my
moonshot zoom my journey has been one of
breaking barriers breaking stereotypes
hearing several knows but in the process
also many people taking a chance on me
and in turn me getting a chance of
creating opportunities for others it has
been a journey from dreaming about being
an astronaut to actually reaching for
the stars today here I'm going to share
with you the three lessons that I
learned in my lifelong journey
the three lessons that mattered most to
me in everything I did and these three
things are passion perseverance and
people actually one easy way to remember
these three lesson is equate them with
the tenants of physics inertia momentum
and catalyst
so let's start with the first principle
passion so your passion for something is
when your love for something is greater
than the fear of failure you love
something so much that you really want
to do it because you're not afraid to
fill what I have come to learn is that
one should only do a start-up when one
is very very passionate about the
problem they're trying to solve because
building a start-up is at and especially
building an enduring startup is seven to
eight years of commitment for example
take example of Jeff Bezos it took him
almost more than two decades to build
Amazon into a company from just selling
a books to selling everything or
anything and delivering to your doorstep
in less than an hour same if you take an
take example of a LAN masque who wants
to change every car on this earth from
gas car to an electric car these are
hard problems to solve and they take
years and years of enduring efforts
that's why it's so important to be
passionate about the problem you're
trying to solve so that you can sustain
and there and be a winner in 2013
actually I was working at eBay I was
leading a platform where four million
sellers used to sell anything in
everything to 250 million customers this
technology-based platform actually
worked like a magic you could sell
anything in a few minutes but in my
personal life I could not solve a very
simple challenge of parenting how to
take my kids from one place to another I
wanted to do well in my career and grow
in it and at the same time be present
for my kids and every day I was
challenged how do I drop my kids in the
morning and yet be there for the
meetings morning meetings with
executives and how to pick my kids at
3:30 p.m. in the afternoon take them to
extracurriculars when I'm supposed to be
at work at 5:00 p.m. when I looked
around I found that it's not just me
everything
parent in the eBay in was facing the
same challenge and upon reflection I
realized thirty years back my mother had
faced the same challenge in a small town
in India and eventually she left her job
to take care of her four kids what I
realized was nothing had changed this
problem spanned geographies it spanned
generations the same disconnect had been
solved in other areas we are on the with
the platforms like Amazon and eBay but
when it comes to parenting this had not
changed it felt like I was failing as a
mother and also as a business leader
this so I started soon to solve this
problem so zoom is a plat with zoom what
we are trying to do is provide parents
with freedom choice and opportunity what
we feel is that no parent should be have
to make choice between their career and
caring for their children this is a
problem I am so passionate about that
I'm willing to do anything and
everything to solve it in an enduring
way today many people especially the
early stage entrepreneurs they admire us
for a success specifically they admire
us for raising a large amount of money
for growing three times year over year
for growing a team to over a hundred
people in just two years
but one misses a point for two years we
did not have any money to run Facebook
or Google Ads we were completely
self-funded with no money from outside
there were two other companies that had
already raised CDs before us and there
were many times we were very close to
closing the company the only reason we
kept on going was just one a passion to
solve this problem at its core so your
passion can not only help you kickstart
a in your startup but it also gives you
unique insights into the area that
you're trying to
so our passion to solve this problem has
led us to ask deeper questions to get
one step deeper into the whole problem
and see how we can solve it at its core
for example at a very beginning stage we
realized that doing digital marketing
and getting customers or acquiring
customers was a very cost prohibitive
thing if we had treated it as a wall
that we cannot surmount I would not be
standing here today instead we started
asking who else would be willing to pay
for these rights how can we subsidize
these rise and acquire customers for
cheaper and in that discussion we
realized that kids go to school every
single day and they commute from school
at least twice every day so they need at
least two rides from school every single
day so we thought why don't we go to
school and find out if school would be
willing to promote us I still remember
the cold call I had met made to the
assistant dean of harker it's a large
private school in San Jose I asked him
hey would you be willing to promote zoom
to your parents he said sorry I can't do
that because we are a non-profit I said
okay then how do you promote other
services to this to the other to the
parents he said because school is using
those services and they are paying for
those services so I'm allowed to do that
I said okay so how do you do your school
transportation that one question let us
do an amazing 35 billion dollar market
which nobody was attacking using
technology it was an antiquated market
which was stuck in 70 year old
infrastructure and nobody was addressing
it so what we started doing was we
pivoted a business model and started
serving schools as part of her business
model and signed multi-year
multi-million dollar contract that
insight and unique insight actually led
us to grow three times year over year
and led us to led to a success that we
have today
so your passion for something is one
thing that can blow away the inertia
that may have the fear of failure that
may have it can actually take you away
from the obstacles that may feel that
you may thank you for your face and help
you reach towards a goal but passion can
only take you so far
so that brings us to our next principle
perseverance perseverance is actually
one of them to me is not giving up even
when the success is delayed or even when
the successes you don't see any part to
the success it's just continuing on your
path till you till you get to the end so
perseverance is actually one of the
quality for entrepreneurs which is
highly unter underrated but it's one of
the most important quality I would say I
have practiced perseverance as a since I
was a kid when I was in middle school
ever since I was in middle school I
started getting up very early in the
morning like 4:00 a.m. to basically get
ahead in the class from everybody and
this habit of perseverance of not giving
up even when it's very uncomfortable
just became part of my life and it it
became my secret superpower
so I every day in the morning what in
this habit enables me to do is make sure
that I'm prepared and I'm ready to lead
a well very smart hungry team this habit
of perseverance is something I have also
applied to other facets of my life for
example I was never ever a runner in
high school actually I hated the short
Sprint's that were there and I never
wanted to run but then in 2016 to
overcome my fear of running and also to
raise money for the cause leukemia that
I deeply care about I decided to
basically run for a full marathon
anybody who knew me would say I'm
kidding but there
I started coaching with a coach and for
three months I coach with them every
week one mile at a time I made progress
slowly but steadily unfortunately at 18
mile Mar I got a stress fracture and my
doctor said that I could not run anymore
I was barred from running it was very
disappointing for me because I had
raised money from hundreds of friends
and had committed basically to raise
money for leukemia and lymphoma society
and complete the Nike Women's Marathon
after couple of days of reflecting
through it
I had an alternate plan I basically
started swimming and started visualizing
how it would be like running again
I missed the 20-mile run I missed the 22
mile run which is the last run before
the 26.2 mile run on the day of Marathon
I showed up and I completed the marathon
there were so many times when that I and
the day when I was running my body
wanted to just give up I wanted to give
up but it was just one thing the
commitment I had made to my friends that
I would I would be running and the
commitment I had made to myself to let
not let anybody down that kept me going
fast forward as a founder perseverance
has really paid us off and has led to
long-term thinking a clear example of
this would be when we were raising
Series A from Sequoia we were going
through the process of due diligence and
the process was going pretty well but we
were not at the final step yet at that
time another ambassador had given us a
term sheet and we basically had one way
to say yes or no to top it all we only
had one month of money left in the bank
and we had to figure out how to pay our
five employees
at that time everybody said that a
burden hand is better than two in the
bush
take it take it now it is the
perseverance that led us to long term
thinking we wanted to build an enduring
company by partnering with a VC that had
actually invested in other law
engineering companies like Apple Google
Dropbox doordash Airbnb we brought a
team on board and basically decided to
say no to the term sheet in hand and we
persisted through the process of Sequoia
due diligence in two weeks we actually
had a term sheet and that became a
defining moment for zoom and I would say
an inflection point for zoom because
that cat that made the things rolling
for us and have us built the company in
a very enduring way so perseverance is a
quality that leads to a momentum that
builds momentum around you which is very
hard to stop once it starts the momentum
actually becomes your superpower and it
compounds into your unfair advantage in
as you build a company or in your life
now passion and perseverance can only
take you so far because what you need is
a third principle people who are
actually going to catalyze your growth
now collaboration creativity and support
are only possible when you surround
yourself with people who have the same
passion and perseverance as you people
are important both tactically and
strategically my professor in the
organization behavior at GSB used to say
you're only good as five people you
interact the most well that makes it
very important that
people that you interact with and have
around you are smarter than you it
becomes extremely important for you to
surround yourself with people who are
better than you I get often asked how do
you unlock the exponential growth in a
start-up the insight that I have is not
new but it's true where by having the
people and the most talented people in
your team because great talent or great
people actually attract the great talent
and that momentum gets keeps building on
you one example of this happened in the
early stages of zoom me and my
co-founder we used to sell the product
market the product build the product do
operations do everything and we just
hired two salespeople by doing that we
actually got to 20-30 school
partnerships but what we really wanted
to do was go grow exponentially
nationwide this was a very lofty goal
and we were not very good in the sales
at all that was not a core skill what we
wanted to do was actually get a sales
leader from outside who could help us
with this
so we found a sales leader who was
perfect for us but in the beginning we
were not perfect for him at all but then
we finally closed him and if you asked
him what made him join us he would say
our passion and perseverance and since
he joined us we have actually grown a
revenue 10x and we have grown to 2,000
schools through partnerships across five
states and not only that he has built a
great team around around that that has
built a very scalable process for us to
keep growing the cells the right team
can make the huge difference for you and
getting your team right is both a
science and an art that you have to find
for your what works for your startup and
hone that as as much as you can
now while while people lead to the
success of a startup people can be
actually number one reason that your
startup will fail I don't know if
you guys have washed professor Greer
video recently she said that the number
one reason you started will fail is
people issues there's a book called
founders dilemma which says that nine
out of ten starters are going to fail
and two-third of the failure happens
because of the people issues these could
be fights between the co-founders this
could be disagreement between what
product do you want to build who do you
want to hire who do you want to where do
you want to sell who do you want to take
investment from any of these problems
can actually kill your startup the speed
the quality of decision that you may the
commitment and consensus that you have
for those decision will actually
determine how innovative your startup is
going to be and how fast can you scale
your startup head zoom actually we have
learned from our mistakes in the
beginning there was a face when we were
hiring leadership team we started going
for very shiny objects just because the
resume a laggard or these people come
with the credentials even when they were
they did not match in the culture or the
values for the company these kind of
mistakes can be very expensive for the
company especially at the leadership
positions because not only these people
impact their work they actually impact
the team's work and the hiring that
happens in the startup fortunately for
us we corrected this problem pretty
quickly and it today we have built an
amazing team now another myth about
people is that people think that to
attract great talent you need a lot of
money in the bank but interesting thing
is what great people get attracted
towards is your mission and your vision
and with what passion and what what
stories do you communicate this mission
and vision to them so this is the kind
of people you want to build your startup
alongside not the people who want who
join you just for the exit or just for
the IPO
so the catalyzing effect of people can
truly be the difference in your startup
being amazing or mediocre I feel blessed
every day coming to the work with the
team that we have built here I hope all
of you will find the people that you can
connect with and work with in your
endeavors and in your life so to
summarize the power of passion
perseverance and people can actually
help you get to your moonshot in my work
I have seen how passion can actually
blow away the inertia perseverance can
help you build a momentum and people can
catalyze growth
I hope the stories and the insights that
I have shared with you actually help
will help you in your activities and
your endeavors I hope the tools and the
insights I've shared today with you help
you reach your journey to the Stars I'll
take your questions now
[Applause]